hey this is presto Walker we have shapes
a and B which of the following shapes
can be formed by joining shapes a and B
together
joining means placing shape a adjacent
to shape B so they share a side select
all of the correct answers from the
following six choices this problem is
from a sample question of the 2017 NAEP
assessment for United States eighth
graders only 7% found all of the correct
answers can you figure it out give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
so from these two shapes which of the
following six shapes can we form
I'll admit that at first I didn't find
all of them I actually only found three
but there are four correct shapes so
let's illustrate them one of the correct
shapes is this right triangle how do we
form it let's take our two shapes a and
B and then let's rotate shape B now the
two shapes have formed this right
triangle another shape that we can form
is this 1 by 2 rectangle we'll start out
with our two shapes and now let's rotate
shape B and then join the two shapes
together this forms this rectangle the
third shape we can form is this
parallelogram we'll illustrate this by
starting out with our two shapes now
let's rotate shape B then rotate shape a
and then join them together the final
shape we can form is this trapezoid how
do we do that
we'll start out with our two shapes now
let's rotate shape B and then rotate
shape a then we'll join them and that's
how we form this trapezoid so to
summarize there are four correct shapes
this right triangle this rectangle this
parallelogram and this trapezoid
furthermore each correct shape has an
area of two the other two shapes are
incorrect because each shape has an area
of four did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
if you like this video you can check on
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon if you have a math topic you can
email me presh at mind your decisions
calm and you can catch me on social
media either at mind your decisions or a
pressure tal Walker